Speaker 1: Let's now take some phone calls.
We're going to hear from people in the audience.
We do this via discord.
They're not really phone calls, but sometimes
it's kind of like hard to explain what they
are if I don't say phone calls.
So I just call in phone calls.
But you go to David Pakman dot com slash discord
and that's where it's all happening.
All right.
Let's go with Adrian from Wyoming and hear
from Adrian first today.
Adrian, what's going on?
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
I have a question for you about what Joe Biden
cares about, because I know there's kind of
a maxim about if presidents really care about
certain issues, they'll do more.
And I'm wondering how you think he's done
regarding trans rights, especially in the
wake of the potential expulsion of a montana
state senator today.
I don't know exactly what's going on with
that.
Speaker 1: I did not see that story.
But let me address that.
You know, here's here's the thing.
With all of these issues, so often this debate
starts about has the president done enough
or not on a particular issue?
And then subsequent to that, the question
becomes how much can a president do about
that particular issue?
And when it comes to trans issues, the unfortunate
reality is that a lot of this stuff is determined
at the state level.
Now, you could say, well, there should be
some overarching federal law protecting trans
people, but we already know from experience
with other issues related to gender and sexual
orientation that that often is not something
that happens or happens quickly.
So I have to admit, I don't know the full
scope of what Biden could do federally to
best evaluate how what kind of a job he's
done, if that makes sense.
Right.
Speaker 3: And I personally but I'm right
with you there.
I realize that in a deadlocked Congress, there's
very little that's potentially going to get
done, especially with the red meat that this
issue unfortunately provides to the Republican
base.
Absolutely.
I just think I just wonder and I just wanted
to hear your perspective symbolically, like
like for when he invited the Tennessee three
over earlier, I believe, this week and just
hosting more events or just talking a little
bit more about those kind of issues just from
that kind of perspective, because I realize
legislatively that he's kind of deadlocked
and not much may get done.
But I appreciate your thoughts on.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I mean, okay, so
Biden could sign executive orders and and
direct federal departments to enact certain
policy protections.
Okay.
So I don't know that he's done a ton of that.
He can use the bully pulpit to talk about
the issue.
I think he has I mean, he brings up trans
issues at many speeches.
So I think they're he's doing okay.
He can appoint officials in his administration
who are defenders of trans rights.
And I think mostly he's done that.
He certainly hasn't appointed anyone I'm aware
of who's hostile or indifferent to trans rights.
So that's okay.
And then he can sort of like push state and
local governments to do one thing or the other.
But the unfortunate reality is the state,
the state governments that would listen to
Biden are already doing pretty well when it
comes to protecting trans people anyway.
And the state governments that are aggressively
persecuting trans people aren't going to care
what Joe Biden says anyway.
So, you know, I think he's doing okay, but
he could always do more.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I fully agree.
I really appreciate it because I know that
my ex-husband, my ex date where I went to
college in Minnesota, their age took a big
step back.
Everyone's either taking big steps up or big
steps back.
And it's just very unfortunate to see right
now.
So I appreciate you taking the call.
Thanks for your perspective.
Hope you have a great day.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you.
There is Adrian from Wyoming.
Let's go next to Jennie-O. From Chester, is
this Chester Springs?
Yes, Jennie-O from Chester Springs.
Welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Hi.
Can you.
Speaker 1: Hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Hi.
Chester Springs, Pennsylvania, outside of
Philadelphia.
Love it.
That's us.
I'm surprised I got that.
Thank you.
So my question is my first question is, I've
always wanted to ask you.
Big fan for a long time.
Do you listen to Howard Stern?
Speaker 1: You know, I've I've been a listener
since I was like age 14.
But if I'm totally honest, since the pandemic
started, I've barely listened at all.
Speaker 4: Oh, really?
Yeah.
Hard to start.
Speaker 1: Listen, I mean, part of it is I
no longer have Sirius radio, so I know that
a bunch of, like, the interviews get posted
to YouTube or whatnot, but I don't have Sirius
anymore.
Speaker 4: I understand.
I understand.
Well, Howard does wonderful interview, just
like you do.
That's why I asked.
Because I feel like he's one of the best interviewers,
and his interviews have gotten better over
the past few years.
I agree.
And I find that you are a wonderful interviewer
as well.
So I thought maybe you had some inspiration.
Speaker 1: I agree that he's a great interviewer
and I appreciate the compliment, but I have
not had the pleasure of listening much lately.
Now, let me ask you this.
For a while he was like down in his house
in Florida doing the show remotely.
Is he back in the New York studio?
Speaker 4: You know what?
I think he's still he's still fully remote.
He's very, very anxious about COVID.
Yes.
Like just getting out.
Like he talks about it almost on a daily basis.
He's just getting out and like meeting friends.
And he's still, like, very worried about it.
And but I, I, I could be wrong.
But I think he's still in his studio in the
Hamptons and his studio in Florida.
Got it.
There he is.
But yeah, I think he's remote still, but he
has like he's had some really good interviews
and they what he his musical guests, they
go to the serious studio in New York, I believe.
All right.
Speaker 1: Very good.
Well, let's let let me not to take time away
from your question.
Speaker 4: I have one other question.
Yeah.
How do you feel about and I might have missed
it here and there about your feelings on Israel
and the Israeli government, because as a Jewish
American and I want to support Israel, but
I have really hard feelings.
I have a hard time supporting Israel, knowing
some of the things that they're doing to Palestinians.
And I just wanted to know, like what your
feelings on that is.
Speaker 1: I have certainly dozens of clips
about this.
I mean, my view is that I am 100% opposed
to these right wing Israeli governments, Netanyahu,
etc..
I'm against illegal settlements.
I would like to see the blockade with Gaza
ended.
And I also recognize that it's simply not
going to end until there are either certain
concessions or assurances that come from Hamas,
which is extraordinarily unlikely.
And it's such a complicated issue.
Genio But I think I'm often attacked as being
a shill for Israel.
And a lot of that is unfortunately, just because
I'm Jewish.
And it's disappointing to see that when it
comes to policy, if you look at I've probably
done it ten times now, if you look at my policy
idea for how to resolve the conflict, I think
it's it's quite fair and both sides could
probably find issue with it.
But I think there's one other important thing.
One of the things that's unfortunate is there
is a standard applied to Israel when it comes
to, quote, supporting the country, which might
include like even going on a trip that no
one applies to other countries, which I would
like to see changed.
Like, for example, if people very few people
see, like, for example, I went to England
when Boris Johnson was the Prime Minister.
I didn't support Boris Johnson, but to say
I won't go there because it's an endorsement
of Johnson, I don't agree with that.
And yet, like when I went to Israel, people
wrote to me saying, How could you you're supporting
settlements, you're supporting Netanyahu because
you're there.
That is like never really applied to other
countries.
And I would like to see that applied a little
more fairly because people came to the US
when Trump was president, didn't mean they
supported Trump.
You know what I'm saying?
Speaker 4: Yeah, for sure.
Now I completely agree with you.
Yeah.
And I also feel like people because, you know,
we're Jewish people feel like we have to support
Israel.
And I support Israel as a country and I support
the people who live there, but I don't support
the government just how people would support
the United States, but they wouldn't necessarily
support Trump.
Speaker 1: And I'll go further than that,
Jenny.
Oh, I'll go even further.
Not only do Jews not have to do anything in
particular when it comes to supporting or
defending or attacking Israel, American Jews
also have no reason to even be answering the
questions about Israeli foreign policy.
I was once at a brunch a couple of years ago
and met someone for the first time and they
started putting me in the position of having
to explain to them about this, that or the
other thing about Israel.
And it's like, I've been there once in my
life.
I'm from Argentina, I've lived in the United
States the vast majority of my life.
I happen to be Jewish, but it's it's kind
of weird to put me in a position of having
to defend or explain anything about Israel.
Ask Israelis, you know.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's so true.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate your response.
Speaker 1: All right.
Jennie-O from Chester Springs beautifully
asked